ما كان مستعصيا على اسلافه حققه رئيس
الحكومه البريطانيه اذ توصل الى اتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لحل مشاكل البروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه الذي يخضع هذا الاقليم
التابعه للتاج البريطاني بعد لقوانين
السوق الاوروبيه الموحده للحفاظ على حدود
مفتوحه بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجارتها
الجنوبيه العضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما
يفرض اجراءات التفتيش جمركيه للبضائع من
انحاء بريطانيا الى هذه المقاطعه الشماليه
سوناك اشاد بهذا الاختراق الحاسم
عن يسعدني ان ابلغكم اننا حققنا تقدما
حاسما معا قمنا بتغيير البروتوكول الاصلي
ونعلن اليوم عن اطار عمل الدستور الجديد
توفر اتفاقيه اليوم تدفقا ثالثا للتجاره
داخل المملكه المتحده باكملها وتحمي مكانه
ايرلندا الشماليه في اتحادنا وتحمي
السياده لشعب ايرلندا الشماليه
اطار عمل وينزر جاء نتيجه التوتر الذي
اثاره بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه بتعطيل
عمل السلطه التنفيذيه المحليه لاكثر من
سنه ناهيك عن بيروقراطيه نقل البضائع الى
المقاطعه الشماليه وستتيح هذه التسويه
الجديده توافر جميع المواد الغذائيه
والادويه البريطانيه في اسواق اراندا
الشماليه عبر مسارين واحد اخضر للبضائع
المتوجهه لايرلندا الشماليه واخر احمر
للبضائع الذي قد تتوجه للاتحاد الاوروبي
كما تعطي المجلس المحلي رايا في القوانين
الاوروبيه التي تحكمهم
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
يقول ريشسوناك ان الاتفاق الجديد مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان بروتوكول ايرلندا
الشماليه يصحح عيوب
والتحدي الذي يواجه ريشيسوناك الان هو
اقناع الاطراف السياسيه هنا في بريطانيا
لقبول هذه التسويه الجديده
على راس هؤلاء الحزب الوحدوي الديمقراطي
في بلفاست الذي جمد صيغه تقاسم السلطه وفق
معاهده السلام بسبب البروتوكول الذي اثر
على التجاره بين بريطانيا وايروندا
الشماليه لابقاء هذه المقاطعه في السوق
الموحده كما سيكون على السوناك كسب اعضاء
حزبه وخاصه جناحه المتشدد في مجموعه
الابحاث الاوروبيه فيما ابدت المعارضات
تاييدها للاتفاق لازاله عقبات وتصحيح
اخطاء البروتوكول السابق
مصبزارو العربيه لندن